bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
dans point de vue pour une nouvelle
semaine de débat de controverse sur
quatre sujets dont je vous propose de
découvrir la teneur en images on attend
incessamment un remaniement
gouvernemental à la suite de la
démission de gérard collomb un
remaniement pour quoi faire pour changer
de politique ou bien simplement pour
essayer de mettre fin à une forme de
désordre on se posera la question
on s'intéressera aussi au réchauffement
climatique avec ce nouveau rapport des
experts du giec qui disent que le
réchauffement pourrait être plus élevé
que prévu
qu'est ce que ça change est ce qu'il
nous faut tout changer dans nos manières
de vivre vous nous donnerez votre point
de vue on s'intéressera aussi à ces
éléments assez divers mais peut-être
qu'ils font système comme on dit
aujourd'hui avec que le candidat
d'extrême droite trahir boys boys sonar
au pardon qui est largement en tête du
premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle au brésil avec marine le
pen qui rencontrent matteo salvini
le ministre de l'intérieur italien avec
steve banane qui essaie de fédérer les
populistes en europe c'est la une du
figaro de ce matin est ce que tout ça
représente un même mouvement ou pas on
le verra et puis on parlera de michel
onfray le philosophe a envoyé une lettre
assez spécial à emmanuel macron avec des
métaphores sexuelles assez explicite ça
lui vaut une déprogrammation sur la
télévision publique sur france 5 cette
censure et qu'elle bienvenus nous nous
nous efforcerons de répondre à cette
question avec nos quatre invités que je
vais vous présenter tout de suite
bonsoir anne fulda vous êtes grand
reporter au figaro responsable entre
autres de la rubrique portrait vous êtes
d'ailleurs l'auteur d'un portrait dans
un livre portrait d' emmanuel macron un
jeune homme si parfait c'est peut-être
ironique
en tout cas ça a été publié chez plon on
en est à 11 traduction dont la dernière
en japonais
respect richard boyer là aussi bonsoir
vous êtes premier adjoint socialiste à
la mairie du 12e arrondissement de paris
expert de la fondation jean jaurès un de
vos l'une de vos spécialités c'est le
sport la société vous avez d'ailleurs
écrit en collaboration le foot va-t-il
exploser ouvrage publié aux éditions de
l'aube et à la fondation jean jaurès
bonsoir marin de viry vous êtes écrivain
critique littéraire membre du comité de
direction de la revue des deux mondes
votre dernier ouvrage un roi
immédiatement a été publié aux éditions
pierre guillaume deux roues et périco
légasse et là aussi bonsoir péricaud
cette journaliste critique gastronomique
rédacteur en chef de la rubrique vin et
gastronomie à marianne votre dernier
livre à table citoyens point
d'exclamation pour échapper à la
malbouffe et sauvé nos paysans a été
publié aux éditions du cerf on attend
incessamment sous peu en tout cas avant
le conseil des ministres de mercredi
prochain un assez large remaniement
ministériel est ce que c'est une simple
péripétie dans la vidéo gouvernement ou
est ce que c'est le reflet d'un certain
désordre
écoutez ce qu'en pense jean pierre
raffarin ancien premier ministre pour
lui c'est quand même un peu le bordel
le centre-droit qui le soutient en
partie et désorganisés sans noyau dur en
marche est toujours en phase
d'adolescence et puis la
social-démocratie le centre gauche
s'évapore donc il est clair que le
président de la république n'a pas les
leviers humains aujourd'hui nécessaire
vous trouvez vous qu'il soit normal
d'attendre huit jours pour changer un
ministre de l'environnement d'attendre
je ne sais combien pour un musée
intérieur donc on voit bien qu'il ya un
problème de ressources humaines
ça c'est une question d'organisation
politique à deux fils va ça sert à quoi
ce remaniement ça sert à remettre un
petit peu de désordre dans cette
organisation un peu des deux désordonnés
que décrit jean pierre raffarin à ça
parce que d'abord il n'y a pas le choix
lorsqu'il ya deux ministres d'état qui
partent successivement politiquement ce
n'est pas rien ça a une signification
politique
même si nicolas hulot avait remplacé
avait été remplacé lors d'un remaniement
dix techniques effectivement mais enfin
lorsqu'il ya un deuxième ministre d'état
a si peu de distance qui lui aussi
démissionne quelles que soient les
raisons il ça devient un problème
politique
voilà donc outre le le problème de
remplacer les gens il faut il faut cette
fois ci que ce remaniement est un sens
politique parce que visiblement il faut
que le président de la république et son
premier ministre commence à faire de la
politique et donc
le ce remaniement évidemment servir à
remplacer gérard collomb ce qui n'est
pas une mince affaire mais il doit
permettre aussi de sauver la face aussi
finalement parce qu'il ya eu ça a été
deux camouflets tout ça sur un fond
d'aidé était assez dramatique avec une
chute dans les sondages qu'on ne cesse
de constater certes on doit pas
gouverner le nez sur les sondages mais
enfin il ya un moment où ça a un sens
donc ce remaniement va se servir je
pense à refaire de la politique aussi et
je ne pense pas que ce sera une nouvelle
politique mais ça sera une forme de
nouvel emballage en tout cas est ce que
ce sera une nouvelle politique
en tout cas il y en a qui n'y croit pas
une seconde qu'ils n'imaginent pas que
le gouvernement puisse changer de ligne
c'est alexis corbière le député de la
france insoumise
il était ce matin au toc le figaro chez
notre ami yves thréard j'ai l'impression
que ce gouvernement soit monsieur macro
monsieur philippe veut continuer dans la
même voie personne n'a fait en temps de
manière significative une autre
orientation de ce que je vois à
l'assemblée nationale façon c'est la
même ligne qui continue sa vie comme une
étoile qui considère que le problème de
ce pays c'est que le code du travail est
un obstacle à trop de règles trop dette
sociale qui sont donnés bon richard
briques ce remaniement c'est comme dans
le guépard il faut que tout change pour
que rien ne change ou que tout demeure
ouais c'était un petit peu ça mais en
même temps c'est une une vraie question
qui est lancé est ce que le maquereau
nice mais finalement peu se réinventer
peut se réinitialiser à la limite tous
les facteurs montrent qu'il faut bouger
l'opinion décroche la politique n'est
pas comprise voir est contestée on a un
président des riches qui s'est installé
comme étant la marque et le slogan
autour de la politique menée depuis un
an et un peu plus voilà la question est
finalement est-ce que ce remaniement
peut être l'occasion pour emmanuel
macron d'inverser les choses et de ré
imaginer une politique
le petit louis parce qu'il n'est jamais
trop tard pour bien faire on va dire
mais le veut-il c'est une autre question
et sur celle là je ne suis pas sûr qu'il
ait donné aujourd'hui les signaux pas de
cette autre politique
or si c'est effectivement un concours et
un casting on va en fait avoir la même
politique avec probablement les mêmes
erreurs à la fin si c'est pour changer
durablement sa politique
ça va là encore est difficile à faire
comprendre aux français et d'autre part
je ne suis pas sûr que ce soit dit les
intentions du président lui même celle
de son premier ministre
je vous pose la question puis après on
pourra faire un tour de table si vous
étiez premier ministre qui feriez-vous
entrée aujourd'hui dans ce dans ce
gouvernement
c'est une bonne question mais je suis
pas forcément le plus à même pour
répondre à cette des socialistes il ya
il ya une tentation je pense dans les
choix possibles dans les scénarii
possibles -de emmanuel macron d'aller
chercher encore un socialiste aller
chercher encore à gauche quelque chose
pour justement un petit peu édulcorée
avec un fond de social sa politique mais
je pense qu'on arrive aussi là un petit
peu au bout de l'exercice
périco légasse qui feriez-vous entrer
dans ce gouvernement si vous en étiez le
patron rouge a pris une mesure bien plus
radicale que ça je supprimais le
gouvernement non j'aurais dissous
l'assemblée nationale et je serais parti
devant un lecteur
quand on a un groupe de 3 158 députés
qui ne pèse que 14 87 % des inscrits on
manque c'est totalement légale à celle
du gouvernement la république on manque
de légitimité démocratique 87% s'est
inscrit le premier touché les secours
des électeurs inscrits qui ont voté pour
la république en marche légiste polish
dati les autres n'ont pas mieux mais
quand on a 3 158 députés un remaniement
un remaniement c'est quand il ya soit on
change d'orientation 84 ou du balançan
d'ailleurs on change complètement de
près ministre soir soit on redistribue à
l'intérieur de la majorité et donc on
remanie parce qu'il faut faire ample et
là on a une majorité qui est plutôt 1358
députés on voit pas on va parce qu'il a
rallié en fait je vois pas pourquoi il
remanie non enfin les noms y voir s'ils
pouvaient ils pourraient dire j'ai
besoin et ça c'était chirac en quatre
sets
alors je vais vous dire je veux dire
monsieur suis un peu cynique du coup je
rentre dans une cohabitation
je vais à rambouillet je laisse le
merdier se débrouiller et en 2022
j'arrive frais comme une colombe et je
dis non non non alors après le
remaniement
pourquoi il manie il a tous les pouvoirs
il fait là on remanie quand on a besoin
de changer de ministres qui ont pris des
décisions contraires
quand on a un prix mais nice qui dit jeu
il a tous les pouvoirs c'est des
marionnettes les ministres ne servent à
rien donc on remanie pas ce qu'il faut
ce sont des fusibles qui ont sauté et il
va en profiter pour dire vous savez qui
c'est qui nous avait dit j'ai changé
c'est sarkozy il a changé et il va nous
faire un gouvernement miracle le premier
de finalement été a loupé et là il va
nous faire le vol gouvernement de la
france au bout de quatorze mois on
attend pour voir sa dette passionnant
comme marin de viry c'est un remaniement
pour rien c'est une mesure
d'organisation c'est ce que je dirai ça
n'a pas véritablement une signification
politique très lourdes je suis
entièrement d'accord avec ce qui vient
d'être dit moi ce que je vois surtout
c'est qu'on manque de candidats de
qualité en fait c'est un peu sale c'est
un peu ça qui me fait peur c'est une
façon qui m'attriste c'est que où sont
les gens qui peuvent remplacer colons
voire faire mieux qu'au long ce qui
semble-t-il est possible ou ceux qui
peuvent ce qu'ils pouvaient faire mieux
que l'eau bon on a trouvé rugy ça me
paraît pas non plus ce qu'on a ce qu'on
aurait pu trouver une mieux bref j'ai un
problème de j'ai un problème de casting
si vous voulez pour le pour le
remaniement
j'ai l'impression qu'on va nous sortir
des personnalités finalement assez assez
acquis qui a qui manquent de
l'antériorité à qui manque de
l'originalité à qui manque delà de la
réflexion et à qui il manque de
l'ancrage alors il avait calé devant
mais nice qui était blanc caire et lots
il avait des vrais projets les vraies
compétences blanc caire c'est fait et
puis parfait il nous faut il nous faut
des blancs caire quoi et comment ça se
fait un feedback qu'on ait apparemment
du mal à trouver des candidats de valeur
est ce que c'est parce que emmanuel
macron finalement à partie à ces jeunes
donc il n'a pas de fidèles autour de lui
sûrement il ya ça il ya aussi le fait
que
il aime s'entourer il a quand même été
élu sur la promesse d'un nouveau monde
et donc l'effacement de l'ancien monde
donc il peut pas s'appuyer sur ce
l'ancien monde
or dans l'ancien monde n'y avait pas que
des que des nas si je puis me permettre
donc ça peut servir aussi parfois
d'avoir un peu d'expérience d'ailleurs
d'une certaine façon gérard collomb
quand il est parti il lui a reproché un
petit peu cette manière de gouverner cet
autoritarisme cette manière de gouverner
avec des crânes d'oeuf technocrates
parisiens arrogant donc dans le
remaniement il peut servir
bon c'est un signal politique ça dure
deux jours ça a un effet qui ne sera pas
les français ça va ça va pas leur
changer leur vie ça c'est sûr néanmoins
ça peut être un signal politique
sisi nomme des technocrates sans
envergure ça n'aura pas beaucoup d'effet
s'il nomme des personnes des personnes
qui sont reconnus comme compétente dans
leur domaine et qui savent aussi parler
aux français parce que ça c'est
important c'est le problème aujourd'hui
enfin il ya certains ministres qui s'en
sortent bien tell tale blank rtl agnès
buzyn aussi mais c'est quand même le
problème de ceux de ce gouvernement est
de ce président de la république c'est
qu'il ne sait pas parler aux français et
à la france
oui en tout cas les français comprennent
pas très bien la façon dont ils leur
parlent que ce soit à colombey les deux
églises ou ailleurs quelques
commentaires un peu narquois dos de nos
internautes sur twitter sur lefigaro.fr
christian nous dit tous les ministres
attendus sont inconnus au bataillon
christian le même constate que macro
hongrie déjà la cartouche du remaniement
gepetto spéculent sur une éventuelle
entrée de bruno julliard gouvernement en
disant voir un meneur de l'unef actif
dans le rejet du cpe comme possible
secrétaire d'état à l'éducation à l'eau
gepetto snasco parce que moi je ne
savais pas que c'était à ce poste là
qu'on pouvait l'attendre est plutôt
entendu parler de la culture
c'est surréaliste et un autre internaute
se dit emmanuel macron va dévisser
encore dans les sondages richard
briguait ce qu'on peut revenir un
instant sur ces ministres venus de la
société civile experts à ses compétences
à jean michel blanquer français muriel
pénicaud ou agnès buzyn la ministre de
la santé
vous travaillez dans un dans un
think tank important la fondation jean
jaurès est ce que tu as beaucoup de ces
profils d'experts avec du sens politique
pourrait devenir ministre
probablement mais l'expérience nous
montre que c'est pas une équation qui
marchent mécaniquement et à tous les
coups parce que là vous avez cités ceux
qui sont restés mais on pourrait citer
laura flessel qui est parti on peut
citer nicolas hulot qui avait claqué la
porte
bref c'était aussi le pari de cette
société civile il ya la culture pour qui
ce n'est pas un succès quand exactement
et donc on a aussi à un moment donné
quelque chose qui est dit à ce
gouvernement c'est que l'alchimie n'a
pas prise et que finalement à vouloir se
séparer aussi peut-être de personnes qui
avaient une expérience en politique pour
composer une équipe gouvernementale
c'était peut-être une erreur et
aujourd'hui on a quand même une
interrogation le système macron était à
un moment donné fondée sur ces nouveaux
profils
c'est un système qui a explosé en vol
c'est un système aujourd'hui qui doit se
je pense rénové et l'expérience en
politique c'est quelque chose qui est
important et je crois que c'est un peu
le message aussi de gérard collomb quand
il est parti avec tout ce qu'il y a
derrière comme ambition pour gérard
collomb mais il a quand même mis avec un
petit caillou sur à la fois l'humilité à
la fois sur la proximité sur voila je
crois qu'il racontait que l'inexpérience
à un moment donné peut pas être la
compétence recherchée pour les postes
ministériels marins de vue on a au moins
une certitude dans ce remaniement c'est
que le premier ministre edouard philippe
va rester c'est plutôt une bonne
nouvelle non c'est un peu une d une des
bonnes surprises de ce sept premières
années de quinquennat mâcon où je crois
que c'est les gars c'est parce que je le
ferai pas pour qui les nouvelles très
neutre en france à part le mauvais choix
des ministres a été nommé il n'est pas
viré au bout de 15 mois
voilà passé il ya rien de particulier
ajouté
moi je vous dis ce qui me ce qui me
frappe surtout c'est le manque de
calibre infra premier ministre
c'est-à-dire juste le niveau ministre
d'état et devrait en 2010 sans réserve
c'était ma vie je ne suis pas
constitutionnaliste mais je connais un
article fort médoc l article 20 c'est le
gouvernement qui détermine et conduit la
politique de la nation voulu par le
général de gaulle et michel debré ça n'a
jamais été appliquée ça sauf en période
de cohabitation
ce qui veut dire que la cinquième
fonctionne vraiment haletant sa lettre a
peur de cohabitation est ce que le
président de la république peut se
retirer un petit peu après grand soir il
a plein de choses à faire qu'il aille
voir les électeurs mais qu'ils aillent
vers le peuple français et il laisse le
premier ministre qui avait requis 15
mois il a prouvé qu'il avait quand même
un peu importe son qui le laisse
gouverner je crois que l'autre ils
demandent que ça de dire laisse pas
faire mes preuves je vais faire l'équipe
gouvernementale tu vas la valider je
mène une politique
on verra bien de tirer les ficelles et
de souvenez-vous la déclaration de
politique générale de loire philippe
elle est précédée d'une déclaration du
président de la république
non mais c'est terrifiant co2 je tiens
tout je contrôle tout en dieu le petit
garçon les revues qui disent aimer jouer
et tu n'y touche pas c'est à moi je te
prête ça paie pas on se tourne vers un
field à la biographe d'emmanuel macron
c'est pas trop son genre de se retirer
sur l'aventin non je pense que c'est
quelque chose qui est intrinsèquement en
lui qui est sa personnalité c'est
quelqu'un qui aime exercer son autorité
on l'a compris on l'a vu néanmoins là
peut-être qui comprendra ce que c'est un
peu son intérêt de laisser le premier
ministre un peu plus sur le devant de la
scène
et d'ailleurs si effectivement il se
passe comme ce qu'on a dit une démission
du gouvernement cela impliquera qui est
un discours de politique générale l'une
aurait légitimé nation relégitimation
pardon du gouvernement cela peut
permettre d'asseoir un peu plus le
gouvernement et l'autorité de d'edouard
philippe en tout cas vis-à-vis de ses
troupes
avec toujours cette spécificité qu'on
rappelle à chaque fois qu'il faut
rappeler à chaque fois c'est qu'il n'est
pas il est censé être le chef de la
majorité gouvernementale mais il ne
l'est pas puisqu'il n'est pas membre de
la république en marche et c'est quand
même une étrangeté institutionnel qui ne
le remporte pas moi
devenir majorité c'est le mot des
remarques ou mal alors quelques
commentaires gaulliste chef de la
majorité parlementaire ça je trouve ça
une vraie enfin c'est une c'est un vrai
progrès c'est un progrès qui on arrive
on laisse le dernier mot à nos
internautes
christian qui trouve que la république
en marche ressemble au radeau de la
méduse sont nombreux archos 10 est
macron qui va en promenade en arménie
point d'exclamation pourquoi pas
l'interrogation est un dernier mois anti
mac y trouve que ma quoi tu rappelons
pour former ces gouvernements une
semaine pour remplacer hulot idem cette
fois jusque là de la méduse skins qui
dans lire la colère de dieu à la fin
quand il est avec les vous savez il est
tout seul sur son radeau on espère que
ce sera vincent de ce film sont exacts
final le réchauffement climatique c'est
un sujet qui revient régulièrement les
experts du giec viennent de rendre
publique une étude selon laquelle le
réchauffement serait encore plus fort
que ce qu'on imaginait on pensait qu'on
aurait un réchauffement de l'ordre d'1 5
degrés d'ici vingt ou trente ans
finalement ça pourrait être plus de 2
degrés bref il ya le feu à la maison et
il faut tout changer
écoutez ce qu'en dit jim ce cas c'est le
coprésident du groupe iii du giec c'est
à dire un des spécialistes de ce thème
alors il faut il faut tout changer nous
dit il changer nos comportements
est ce que vous y êtes prêt on vous pose
la question à vous chers internautes
répondez-nous sur sur twitter et sur le
figaro.fr
on va aussi la pause et aux invités sur
ce plateau regardez ce panneau avec
toutes les toutes les possibilités pour
réduire son empreinte carbone
alors on peut changer ces ampoules mais
ça sert pas à grand chose on peut avoir
un enfant en moins là l'impact est réel
on peut le changer de mode de locomotion
ou bien renoncer à un vol
transatlantique
petit tour de table vous êtes prêt à
faire quelque chose de tous à vous tous
pour lutter contre le réchauffement
richard bride tout à fait mais moi ya
déjà des choses que j'aime et que
j'applique donc abandonner ma voiture à
la voiture à essence gelé déjà fait au
nom ça on est obligé quand on est un élu
parisien non il n'ya pas d'oublier ces
scarabées d'algues au nom anne hidalgo
n'est pas cette personne qui
m'obligerait à ne pas avoir de voiture
et pas avoir de voiture à essence il se
trouve que je suis cohérent avec la
politique qui est menée par anne hidalgo
c'est un petit peu différent qu'il
souhaite jouer au haut niveau
renault s'est relancé un vol
transatlantique oui pourquoi pas si ça
devait être fait évidemment proposé
acheter de l'énergie verte oui je le
fais déjà
donc ça c'est quelque chose que je
serais déjà abandonné la voiture
électrique non parce que j'ai pas de
voiture électrique donc je ne les
abandonne pas et je ne vais même pas
acheter donc on va dire quoi là et je
prends que celles qui sont bien sûr dans
la partie dans la partie verte donc
celles qui ont le plus d'impact puisque
j'ai déjà fait des choses dans le sud
donc oui au-delà simplement du du
sondage vous avez bien compris que ce
qui nous est proposé ses devoirs suite à
ce rapport du giec je rappelle juste ans
et un rapport qui a été commandé en 2015
pour qu'on puisse voir justement
l'évolution aujourd'hui à 1.511 degré et
demi de plus ce que donnerait un petit
peu le panorama est ce que nous dit
aujourd'hui ce rapport et c'est le titre
a d'ailleurs de votre question c'est
qu'est ce que ça change ça change tout
ça change tout un degré et demi ou deux
degrés à la fois le niveau de la mer
n'est pas le même ses 10 millions
d'habitants qui sont impactés en plus
nous dit le rapport selon qu'on passe
d'un an et demi à deux degrés
c'est des été sans banquise c'est un
tous les siècles à un ennemi c'est un
tous les dix ans si on est à 2 degrés de
réchauffement pourquoi parce que quand
on passe un an et demi il ya une
accélération ne peut plus revenir en
arrière et donc les écosystèmes sont
beaucoup plus fragilisés ça s'accélère
c'est pour ça qu'il ya cette espèce
d'urgence qui est donné donc oui il faut
à la fois que les gouvernements les
états mais je crois qu'on l'a bien
compris lordat comme 21 l'agenda des
solutions ce que les citoyens les
associations peuvent mettre en place ce
que les villes veulent mettre en place
pas que paris mais notamment panne est
plus important a finalement parfois que
ces grands accords qui tarde à entrer
dans les faits même si on a remarqué que
c'était plutôt une bonne évolution en
marin de viry il ya des choses que vous
êtes prêts à faire ou à ne pas faire
dans le petit listing là quand vous a
proposé au début de l'émission
je sais pas moi je m'en accusés au
tribunal de l'écologie mais en fait j'ai
quatre enfants je vois pas comment je
pourrais en avoir un amour je veux bien
ne plus en faire
j'ai fait trois rues d'auch je comprends
pas très bien le sens de la question
pour les gens qui ont déjà des enfants
sinon on verra ce cas derrière ça dès
qu'il voit une forme de malthusianisme
il faudrait que je recommande aux miens
d'en avoir moi même à l'argenté non je
dois donc et pour le reste
à vrai dire à vrai dire je jeu non je ne
suis jeune je ne suis pas capable de
vous dire que j'ai fait quelque chose
dans ce domaine morts par contre je suis
capable de vous dire parce que
professionnellement je vois beaucoup
d'impact de changement climatique sur
des sur par exemple sur le café tout
simplement tu prenais ça c'est
absolument dramatique 2% 2 % de
température en plus durablement sur les
gaves et ce sur le thé c'est la même
chose et c'est là il ya vraiment des
migrations liées à la voile à la
destruction des cultures à travers le
changement climatique qui sont déjà en
train de ceux qui sont déjà en train de
se créer donc effectivement favoriser
woods hole à riga la parole vous la
gardez jeu jusqu'au signe tout s'est
tellement insuffisant c'est tellement
plus grave que ça il faut repenser tout
à l'heure je suggérais la dissolution
d'assemblage pour les mesures
maximaliste non faut penser c'est pour
ça qu'on vous invite pour penser qu'il
faut repenser carrément la croissance
était au libéral cette planète avec
cette dimension démographique et ce qui
lui reste de ressources ne peut pas
faire face à l'avenir si on ne repense
pas la croissance donc je suis sensible
aux théories de pierre rabhi une
austérité heureuse faut tout repenser
mais il faut le faire parce que l'écho
21,6 a pas un gendarme qui vous donnait
comme quoi sur le cas grec sur les
doigts ça ne sert à rien la chine les
etats unis sont un peu voyou dans cette
logique donc où il ya une vraie
contrainte internationale avec une
espèce de new line peuvent pas un
conseil de sécurité environnementale on
peut toujours rêver mais si on n'arrête
pas tout de suite vous savez c'est le
sketch de fernand raynaud le mur se
rapproche ouf il était temps
la maintenance est poussée plus à allah
c'était il ya dix ans qu'il fallait
faire ça il faut repenser la croissance
mondiale et changer nos moeurs
nous n'avons pas besoin de consommer
autant de choses à une fréquence aussi
proche voilà donc faut le repenser nous
dans l'autre tous alimentaire
la voiture les vêtements voilà faut
faire attention il ya une ressource fixe
sur la planète
vous savez qu'on est déjà débiteur on a
déjà entamé les ressources des
générations à venir
c'est terrible on tape dans le petit
cochon de nos enfants donc où on arrête
tout de suite avec une décision
planétaire alors une vraie globalisation
pour le coût intelligente et une
commission de bruxelles qui mène la
danse l'europe donné l'exemple parce que
nous sommes quand même le pays de galles
à la civilisation de coûts de
consommation où on fait ça
courageusement et voilà ou maquereau est
génial il nomme le premier ministre en
disant voilà edouard philippe renard est
il dit tu t'en vas pas non seulement toi
pas que tu prends matignon et tu fait de
la france le pays qui sera le premier à
montrer l'exemple sur freinage de la
croissance en faisant du beau du bon
libéralisme de tocqueville bien il
s'agit de la première personne mais on
arrête de faire cette surenchère avec
les grandes surfaces soit
surconsommation bon à mon projet
quelques me commentaires d'internautes
christian nous dit j'ai déjà du mal à
payer mon loyer mes factures alors payer
plus cher c'est pour les bobos point
d'exclamation
ça al'air humoristique mais pas que on
en reparlera peut-être tout à leurs
babines et on nous dit il faut une
politique gouvernementale d'envergure
sur le climat comme hulot le souhaitait
babineau qui est un légat siens donc on
à mort sur ce sujet gepetto nous dit le
problème se réglera lui même quand les
hydrocarbures seront épuisées
jean-michel demande des sanctions pour
les gros pollueurs de type états unis
indochine et cet autre commentaire le
gouvernement doit montrer l'exemple
montré le chemin
or il ne le fait pas on recule d'à votre
point de vue sur ce sujet je sais pas si
je je je militerai pour la nomination de
nicolas willot comme premier ministre
quoique en fait je suis a su assez
d'accord avec mérico parce que je pense
que là les rapports s'accumulent
année après année les cris d' alerte
s'accumulent il ne se passe rien donc il
faut un électrochoc et revenons à
nicolas hulot pourquoi les termes qu'il
a utilisée quand il a expliqué sa
démission
il a dit je pars parce que je ne sers à
rien c'est ça qui l'a dit sert à rien
donc ça veut dire que ça s'est mise en
garde c'était peut-être pas la bonne
personne j'en sais rien mais ses mises
en garde n'ont pas été entendus
il y a il faut effectivement un
électrochoc qui doit se se produire pas
seulement au niveau national on voit
bien c'est c'est un changement de
culture radicale alors est-ce que c'est
l'âge d'or dans l'application exact je
suis pas sûr d'être complètement
d'accord avec vous néanmoins il faut un
électrochoc que lala sinon on va encore
avoir rapport dans deux ans qui dira la
même chose et il se passe rien mais
parce que vous parliez du signal
d'alarmé de nicolas hulot mais il n'est
pas le seul à en avoir lancé écoutez ce
que disait emmanuel macron c'était déjà
il y a dix mois on peut pas on ne pourra
pas dire qu'on ne sait pas c'est ce
qu'on est en train de décider à ne pas
changer on décide juste qu'il y en a
plusieurs
autour de cette table qui vont
disparaître leur population avec eux ce
que nous entamons aujourd'hui c'est le
temps de l'action
parce que l'urgence est devenue
permanente
c'est ce même à cran qui s'exprimait au
moins deux planètes se mettent à paris
en décembre dernier
on se demandait si les gens étaient
vraiment mobiliser là dessus regardez la
question du jour c'est sur le figaro.fr
êtes vous prêt à payer votre énergie
plus chère pour lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique
voyez il ya quand même une majorité qui
dit non comment est-ce qu'on peut
expliquer marin de viry 7 ce contraste
entre le ccri d'alarm quasiment
quotidiens et ceux relatifs des intérêts
quand même de la population mais parce
que la motivation fondamentale elle
passe par la solvabilisation du marché
de la transition énergétique à
l'écologie c'est trop cher oui enfin
l'écologiste rochelle si vous avez
comment dirais-je une masse critique
d'entreprises du cac 40 qui sont
directement intéressés à faire la
transition écologique
si vous avez une politique fiscale
d'accompagnement si vous avez un
accompagnement administratif un
accompagnement territoriales etc
on commence à pouvoir voir des leviers
mais est ce que véritablement où les
choses les politiques sont pensées de
telle sorte à aboutir à cette
mobilisation et m
c'est à mobiliser ses moyens je ne le
pense pas donc
donc on peut avoir comme ça deux ou
trois ou quatre hulot qui ne servent à
rien parce que il faut de la solvabilité
regardez regardez les mesures sur leurs
gardes et les mesures sur les hybrides
sur les voitures hybrides
regardez les mesures sur les 1 sur
l'isolation des bâtiments sont des
mesures qui fonctionne à la condition
qu'ils aient de l'incitation fiscale qui
est une forme de deux seules villes de
solvabilisation n'y a pas qu'elle y en a
d'autres voilà richard brooks est un peu
désespérant 7
cette forme de désintérêt des français
pour cet enjeu écologique pour vous qui
vous ne l'avez expliqué être très
sensibilisée à ce sujet moi je ne pense
pas qu'il ya une déresponsabilisation
l'une des motivations je pense que la
manière partant dont on pose le débat
est souvent maladroite et je pense en
plus que on a donné l'un jeudi un bon
collectif
on a donné l'impression que on était un
petit peu avec plusieurs alertes qui
nous sont arrivées le rapport du giec
est un des rapports les plus optimistes
par rapport au rapport de précédents
scientifiques qui nous avait dit qu'en
gros on était vraiment très mal parti là
on nous dit on est mal parti mais il ya
encore le temps et l'espace pour des
solutions donc c'est presque un rapport
optimiste le rapport du giec par rapport
à ce qu'on a lu mais je pense qu'à un
moment donné les décideurs politiques ne
peuvent pas un moment donné entendre ces
rapports les commander et ne rien en
faire je pense effectivement qu'il faut
arrêter qu'il faut maintenant prendre
les décisions et le discours d' emmanuel
macron il ya dix mois est à remettre
pratiquement au regard des décisions qui
ont été prises par le gouvernement sur
ces dix derniers mois et qui montre qu'à
un moment donné et dans le réchauffement
climatique et dans la transition
écologique
on a pris des mesures de la part de ce
gouvernement qui allait à l'encontre on
dit qu'on veut en gros améliorer la
santé des français mais quand il faut
interdire le glyphosate c'est compliqué
quand il faut subventionner plus
durablement l'agriculture biologique
on supprime les subventions et on dit
qu'il faut aller plus vite sur tout ce
qui est la fin des centrales à charbon
mais on traîne et on dit qu'il faut
changer le mix énergétique eon
reprennent encore bref il ya un temps où
un moment donné on peut entendre les
paroles mais quand il s'agit de passer à
l'action
et moi je crois que c'est ça qui
désespère les français c'est le décalage
entre le temps de la parole et le temps
de l'action
quelques éléments épars mais qui
peut-être
disent quelque chose de l'époque jaillir
boys hoarau le leader d'extrême droite
brésilien est arrivé très largement en
tête hier du premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle dans son pays
marine le pen rencontre aujourd'hui
matteo salvini le ministre de
l'intérieur italien simone qui a été
l'un des proches conseillers de donald
trump rêve de fédérer l'ensemble des
mouvements populistes européens ça fait
la une du figaro de ce matin est ce que
tout ça c'est un même mouvement
est ce qu'il ya une cohérence écoutez ce
qu'en pensent les géographe christophe
guilluy
c'est lui qui avait inventé le concept
de france périphérique son dernier livre
s'appelle ne se salit la fin de la
classe moyenne et il était ce matin sur
le plateau de conversation avec marie
laëtitia bonavita ce qui arrive
aujourd'hui n'est absolument pas de
conjoncture n'est pas lié au talent de
tel ou tel populiste au talent d'un
trump à la coupe de cheveux de trump ou
au talent de salvini et c'est la vague
populiste qu'on appelle la vague
populiste un peu partout dans le monde
c'est à chaque fois et pourtant il ya
des contextes nationaux qui sont
différents les mêmes ressorts ça repose
sur deux choses un territoire france
périphérique amérique périphériques le
monde des périphéries une petite ville
villes moyennes zones rurales et une
sociologie la sociologie
c'est effectivement le meilleur est
représenté par ce socle de l'ancienne
classe moyenne 1 des catégories modestes
populaire et vous allez retrouver ce
schéma quel que soit le pays
marin de viry ya une qui s'est toujours
le même mouvement cela c'est une casse
mayenne en voie de paupérisation qui se
révoltent contre la mondialisation pour
faire très très court
oui enfin ça que ce sont quand même des
mouvements nationalistes et des enfin là
on s'est assez drôle que quand on voit
marine le pen et selvigny on a besoin on
se dit que les nationalistes ont du mal
à faire d'aidé internationale si je puis
dire c'est faire ce qu'elle parle c'est
logique parce qu'au bon réalité sont des
gens qui vise pas du tout les mêmes
objectifs qui n'ont pas du tout les
mêmes intérêts et c'est parce qu'ils
sont nationalistes voyez la différence
par an contre sale vignes et marine le
pen sont tous les deux contre
l'immigration dans l'entreprise et dans
la mesure où ces deux préférence
nationale
or si vous voulez c'est la même chose
mais dans la mesure où ces deux
préférence nationale d'abord ça paraît
assez difficile de dégager des
politiques communes l'idée de l'europe
etc etc
bon donc moi je vois l'extrême droite je
vois l'extrême droite comme le résultat
de ce que dit julie c'est à dire
fondamentalement une comment dirais-je
un déficit des politiques sur le plan de
l'explication la pédagogie vis-à-vis de
tous les désespérés vis-à-vis de tous
les laissés pour compte mais pas
seulement aussi les gens qui tout
simplement ne se sentent pas représentés
qui vont pas forcément très mal bon
c'est une violence et on d'isère en
france il ya toujours une clientèle pour
l'extrême droite et ça va jamais au delà
de 30 % ça commence à être faux c'est à
dire que c'est en train de passer en ce
moment 2 3% et c'est un mouvement qui
est possible partout en europe et est
extrêmement regrettable qui voient leurs
collègues à tout ça c'est le même
mouvement dont je suis très étonné qu'en
république française dialectiquement et
intellectuellement utilise le mot
populisme populiste ça veut dire il va
dans le sens de la population ça veut
dire qu'on a un mépris du peuple
terrible
ce sont des mouvements qu'ils ont des
options des orientations politiques
mais le populisme c'est un ultra
démagogues qui fait 2 3% et qui fait des
propositions totalement folle parce
qu'ils aient qu'il n'y aura jamais là
c'est le peuple français c'est le peuple
italien
donc c'est pas populiste et le peuple
français c'est le peuple italien donc
utiliser l'air c'est utiliser le mot
populiste c'est faire le lit du fascisme
à là pour le coup c'est la fascisation
la société bannissant le terme populiste
du débat politique et démocratique ce
sont les partis qui ont des convictions
ils sont arrivés au pouvoir par le
suffrage universel face à l'échec aux
mensonges et autres au prix les autres
partis alors qu'aux régions les
mensonges qui les ont amenés maréchal
pétain 10e et ses branches en ski c'est
emmanuel berl voilà
rectifions dans le monde mais non c'est
pour ça donc c'est absurde seront là
on n'en sort plus rectifions ce qui fait
que ces populations massives à travers
le suffrage universel dans le monde
entier etats unis brésil hongrie c'est
quoi c'était des fachos ces gens là lady
million et demi d'électeurs de denis
front national et les italiens qui ont
voté salvini c'était les citoyens qui
voter à gauche qui voter communiste
il ya pas longtemps ce sont des gens
exaspérés indigné de voir le mensonge et
le vol s'installer en or on leur a
promis ils ont cru à ses promesses
ils ont cru au rêve européen ils ont cru
quelques paroles et aux lèvres libéral
on leur a tout promis et aujourd'hui
c'est une catastrophe générale ces gens
là sont dans un instant de rêve alors ce
sont des révoltés
ce ne sont pas des populistes alors que
les autres fassent évidemment
bénéficient de ce mouvement
il n'empêche que j'en reviens à la
formule de fabius tout c'est parti avec
lequel je ne partage rien il pose quand
même les bonnes questions auxquelles
pour l'instant nous avons apporté des
mauvaises réponses
richard bruit je revenais sur ce que
disait christophe guilluy dans le le
bout des missions là que vous avez
présenté ça marche pas pour le brésil ce
que dit christophe guilluy puisque en
fait on s'aperçoit que c'est pas la
population pauvre c'est pas la
population avec un niveau d'éducation et
de formation initiale infra qui a voté
pour le candidat de l'extrême droite
c'est au contraire les couches les plus
aisées de la société de d'ailleurs c'est
parce que on lui posait la question sur
le mouvement européen on lui posait pas
la question sur le brésil c'est
peut-être pour ça qu'il a répondu comme
ça sur les sur les sur les trois
graphiques un qu'on a on voit quand même
que sur la population qui est la plus
élevée à la fois dans la formation
initiale et dans cet emploi elle et elle
a voté très majoritairement pour le
candidat de l'extrême droite quand on va
sur la population qui est la moins fort
mais la moins éduquées c'est le cas le
moins de pouvoir d'achat et de csp
plutôt basse là on s'aperçoit que c'est
pas exactement la même chose et le parti
travailliste est un petit peu devant
l'extrême droite sur les sondages tels
qu'ils sont sortis pourquoi je dis ça
parce que en france ce serait pas du
tout la même chose
l'électorat frontiste on voit bien à
plutôt des ressorts dans une population
qui est plutôt celle qui est moins
qualifiés moins formés que celle des des
grandes des grandes csp + et d
bon bagage intellectuel et universitaire
pourquoi ici ça c'est quand on dit est
ce que c'est la même chose c'est pas
forcément la même chose parce que quand
même c'est à la fois relié à des
histoires de l'extrême droite qui sont
pas forcément les mêmes l'extrême droite
au brésil a une histoire qui n'est pas
exactement l'histoire de l'extrême
droite en france ni celles en italie et
sa jour à un moment donné quand on a des
un candidat d'extrême droite au brésil
qui ne cesse de faire des allusions à ce
qui s'est passé dans les années la
dictature c'est pas exactement ce qu'il
est possible de faire pour sa vigne est
ce qu'il est possible de faire pour
marine le pen mais ça ne veut pas dire
qu'il n'ya pas à un moment donné des
envies des projets communs et je suis
d'accord
sa prospère sur les défaillances des
précédents gouvernements et au brésil et
au brésil le ras-le-bol du ptc notamment
le ras-le-bol des scandales du ptc
l'insécurité qui a augmenté ces
dernières années on voit bien qu'elles
aient gagné d'anjou là exactement on
voit bien qu'il ya des comptes mais il
ya quand même des contextes nationaux
qui fait que tout relié c'est à la fois
tu entends et en même temps attention il
ya bien des particularités qui sont
celles de l'histoire unique simulant un
champ était en prison ça donne cela
modifierait les jalons la carte
électorale française emprisonnée pour
rapts et autres c'est ce qui s'est passé
quand leader et le président lula qui a
été mis en prison pour corruption
anne fulda dont vous êtes d'accord le
brésil c'est loin en revanche le
phénomène européen vous le trouvez assez
univoque
c'est vrai qu'on semble voir dans le
phénomène européen mais ce qu'est ce qui
a été excellent et mendient par julie
c'est ce sentiment commun de d'exclusion
d'impression de d'une classe populaire
qui n'est pas entendu qu'ils rencontrent
des problèmes qui ne sont pas pris en
compte par les classes dirigeantes et et
on revient toujours à la même chose
cesser ces problèmes on les connaît
c'est les problèmes d'immigration
d'intégration de l'islam radical
et il ya la majorité des personnes qui
apportent leur voix au parti populiste
se sentent finalement incompris quoi
incompris et surtout pas entendu c'est
vrai donc le point commun c'est ça c'est
l'exclusion et le sentiment
d'incompréhension des pouvoirs en place
quelques réactions d'internautes anti
mac nous dit je pense qu'il a les
différences de niveaux et de cause en
matière de populisme c'est un petit peu
l'idée qu'on a effectivement développer
tandis que sébastien estime que l'erreur
dé gauche du monde entier a toujours été
de nier l'importance de l'aspect
identitaire dans la structuration des
sociétés humaines et lino nous dit
arrêtez de croire que le problème est la
pédagogie
les gens ne sont pas bêtes il ya
peut-être un paradoxe dans ce dans ce
mouvement peut-être d'unification en
marche des populistes européens même si
j'avais colegas je n'aime pas
l'expression c'est que c'est un
américain qui est un peu à la manoeuvre
assaf elle a la une du figaro de ce
matin à ce type banane qui était l'homme
qui avait conseillé donald trump et
justement c'est un peu paradoxal que ce
soit un non-européen d'ailleurs ça pose
un petit problème quand même marine le
pen
ecoutez-la parler de steve banane
monsieur banane n'est pas issu d'un pays
européen
il est un amérique la force politique
qui d'être à des élections en europe
c'est nous et nous seuls qui la
structurent rond car nous sommes
attachés à notre liberté
attachés à notre souveraineté un marin
de viry donc banane peut-être mis hors
jeu mais quand même on entend dans la
déclaration de marine le pen donc
c'était ce matin à romain au moment de
la conférence de presse commune avec
matteo salvini une volonté de faire
naître une force politique comme m je
suis assez étonné qu'elle se sentent
gênés par le par la position qu'a prise
banen visons en quelque sorte a
structuré ou a donné l'un
mouvement populiste parce qu'en réalité
elle avait pas besoin de s'en défendre
et je ne comprends pas pourquoi je ne
comprends pas pourquoi il s'en est
défendue non ça peut être récupéré le
maquereau nice n'a produit royer
finalement ah oui c'est un moment vous
êtes en tire une artiste mais finalement
vous mais moi j'étais votre coin du
monde d'accord un agent de l'étranger
est une tradition
remy jouer ce rôle la marine le pen il
ya quelques mois en arrière avant une
présidentielle est un débat télévisé je
crois qu'elle aurait bien aimé être
celle qui a justement était la chef
d'orchestre de ce mouvement en europe
elle aurait bien aimé ça elle avait
quand même organiser plusieurs fois des
rassemblements dans lesquels elles
étaient invités les derniers à cologne
ou autres où elle rassembler l'extrême
droite d'ailleurs où il y avait déjà eu
des tensions puisque certains partis
n'avaient pas souhaité être sur la photo
de famille entre guillemets donc je
crois qu'elle a aussi envie de reprendre
un peu la main
sachant qu'avec salvini elle joue un
tango qui est compliqué anne fulda
est-ce qu'il faut forcément un leader
européen pour ce mouvement bien est ce
que chacun peut réussir dans son dans
son propre pays
sachant comme le disait marin de viry
que ce sont quand même des mouvements
nationaux ou nationalistes donc c'est
bien ça tremble voilà ça semble
effectivement paradoxale qui est un
mouvement européen pour des mouvements
qui se veulent tous nationalistes et
donc pour le le retour de la primeur du
primat de la nation donc bon et puis mon
marine le pen ne me semble pas vraiment
en position de force pour pour avoir ce
rôle
aujourd'hui je pense qu'elle est elle
est encore marquée par sa défaite de la
présidentielle qui qui a été aussi
observés à l'étranger je pense donc
c'est sûrement pas elle qui aura ce rôle
si jamais un tel rôle doit émerger
oui puis elle contrairement à cette
dernière n'est pas au pouvoir attention
les nationalismes les nationalismes
savent s'unir
on a vu dans on a vu dans l'histoire des
partis nationalistes s'unir on en a des
souvenirs catastrophique donc ne disons
pas que par pascal nationalistes on est
en autarcie
il ya des solidarités nationaliste et
même internationaliste qui peuvent avoir
des conséquences qui a passé en tout cas
c'est vraiment la fin de l'idée de
l'europe des patries 1
l'idée gaulliste et aujourd'hui j'ai
l'impression que ça représente à peine
10 % si je peux dire des voix qui
s'expriment sur la question nationale
européenne européennes ou nationales
le réveil patronat il représente quand
même des gens qui veulent réinscrire la
nation et la patrie à l'ordre du jour de
leur destin oui en même temps que
l'europe mais les monarques directe à la
vie d'accord mais cette dialectique la
quête une dialectique raisonnable
gaulliste traditionnels etc qui a droit
de cité en fait dans le débat politique
français j'ai l'impression qu'elle est
très très très malade et poignant oui
oui c'est ça c'est ça fait 5 + 5 6 % oui
dans sa définition les gîtes wade dans
sa définition légitime pas et laurent
qui pourrait prendre la place
oui si le boulot et qui peut-être aussi
que tous ces mouvements
populiste nationaliste on les appelle
comme on voudra ils ont peut-être
différent mais ils peuvent voter
ensemble une fois qu'ils seront élus au
parlement européen
parce que n'oublions pas que c'est ça la
prochaine et c'est en ça fait longtemps
que le npd représente plus le gaullisme
le général a dit là il a fait du
ventilateur autres joueurs ont-ils
entendu au niveau macro parler en son
nom
voilà les gaullistes quelque chose de
très précis le très grand et c'est vrai
et c'est un paradoxe
il est très peur il est très peu
présente c'est que pour le moment
aujourd'hui la campagne n'est pas lancée
mais les intentions de vote pour marine
le pen aux élections européennes je le
contexte sont plutôt en deçà de ce qu'on
pouvait attendre d'elle 20% finalement
sait pas exactement ce qu'on pouvait
attendre sur une élection habituellement
elle pouvait aller plus loin et où
surtout elle est dans l'opposition à un
gouvernement
tu ne fonctionne pas ce qui prouve bien
que la trace laissée par la
présidentielle est encore un peu
présentes notamment chez les simples
après jugement c'est un miracle une fois
que la bourse en voilà moi je dis le
vert à l'autre sens après le débat de
l'entre-deux de l'entre-deux-mers
qu'elle fasse encore 20% celle ci
préfère 12
merci il y a une dizaine de jours la
pression d'un public que
et est sur l'île de saint martin il
s'est fait prendre en photo avec deux
jeunes gens qui en ont profité pour
faire un doigt d'honneur
cette scène n'a valu au président une
lettre ouverte du philosophe michel
onfray
revenant sur cette photo polémique
filant de façon explicite la métaphore
sexuelle
je voudrais vous faire réagir sur une
décision qui a été prise par une chaîne
de télévision publique france 5 en
l'occurrence et la présentatrice d'une
de ses émissions marina carrère
d'encausse de ne pas inviter michel
onfray à la suite de cette de ceux de
cette attitude mais s'est montré lui se
défend en disant mais j'ai le droit moi
aussi à la satire écoutez il était ce
matin sur ses news est ce qu'on a le
droit d'être charlie quand on est
philosophe
est ce qu'on a le droit de faire ce que
par exemple font les dessinateurs de
siné de charlie hebdo le canard enchaîné
quand on est philosophe c'est à dire
utiliser une tradition qui est celle de
la satire alors pour lancer le débat je
propose de prendre connaissance de cette
déclaration d'un monsieur qui s'appelle
christian gerin vous savez sur l'autre
pas qui c'était moi non plus c'est
l'ancien producteur du magazine de la
santé donc l'émission de france 5 dont
michel onfray a été déprogrammée et
voilà ce qu'il dit j'ai appelé marina
carrère d'encausse pour lui dire tu
déconnes à plein tube
je trouve le texte de michel onfray
graveleux et de mauvais goût mais c'est
au tribunal de juger s'il est homophobe
c'est lamentable de les commander pour
ces raisons de quel droit on sent sur un
philosophe on est un peu là sur la
question de principe l'au delà de cette
polémique
est-ce qu'on censure est ce qu on ne
censure pas marin de viry
j'ai lu enfin plus exactement j'ai
écouté le message vidéo qu'il a dans son
entièreté qu'il a fait dans son
entièreté ses logiciels en frais celui
michel onfray absolument à lui sa lettre
sur son sur son compte tout est
absolument absolument savoir que moi je
trouve d'ailleurs point je n'ai pas vu
la moindre trace de mots folie mais peu
importe qui paraît alors aujourd'hui
j'ai l'impression que ce thème là près
de moi ce qui me frappe surtout avec un
coffret dans cette affaire c'est que il
a raison de le noter les ier ya un prêt
de deux catégories
moi je ne pense pas qu'on ferait selon
un philosophe au sens où j'appelle
la j'appelle philosophe philosophe si je
peux dire c'est autre chose c'est une
sorte de commentateurs était bon et puis
il a il est rentré dans la catégorie des
proches au fond c'est le tribunal des
flagrants délires sa lettre je sais pas
si vous l'avez andreu on a l'impression
que celui des proches - les états forts
filet massara comment dirais-je cette
espèce de lexique formidablement richer
et drôle qui avec avait des proches mais
bon c'est ça voilà c'est ça
effectivement il file la métaphore
sexuelle et même homosexuel ça c'est
clair mais c'est pas du tout pour autant
homophobes
voilà et je ne vois vraiment pas au nom
de quoi il pourrait y avoir la moindre
censure alors vous vraiment pas au nom
de quoi y avait la moindre censure je ne
comprends même pas l'idée qu'on puisse
dire que ceci engendre une réaction du
service public enfin ou alors on est
dans un monde différentes marques je
pense que c'est pts c'est quand même
pour moi c'est une la photo est une
oeuvre d'art avec le présent la plus
française
je vois de gaulle avec un doigt au
pompidou avec un doigt voilà avec deux
mots de deux beaux garçons dépoitraillé
et puis alors dans cette intimité
c'est magnifique c'est un changement
c'est un changement de civilisation
c'est une oeuvre d'art et le texte de
michel onfray en bas c'est l'autre
oeuvre d'art qui répond ah ça oui voilà
à part ça je pense qu'un jour on censure
pas c'est pas cela c'est que on a
tellement peur parce que il peut se
cacher la lettre elle est quand même
elle est terrifiante quand j'ai lu gt et
on me l'a fait dire parce que l'on m'a
fait regarder parce que c'était bien lui
et je michel l'économie et j'étais
scotché et quand même et je pense que
l'ire présidentielle parce qu'il peut
être rancunier pour la république quand
on lui fait des blagues de ce genre et
les journalistes ont déjà peur si
l'invitons frère faisait il va être dit
va être éliminé parce qu'on a peur alors
déjà salée quand on dit en france ils
étaient cent ans on le sait la diffusion
je crois de ses conférences et concerts
tueur qui s'arrête mais c'était
l'anniversaire de temps ça c'était avant
voilà donc ça donc france culture a
décidé d'arrêter la diffusion et la sai
france axé sur une émission qui est une
émission de santé donc il n'allait pas
parler du président de la république il
allait parvenir sur cette lettre la con
l'homme qu'on aime pas qu on trouve que
le style est un peu moyen graveleux
même pas vraiment celui d'un fils devait
témoigner de de l'avc qu'il avait eu
donc
donc voilà il devait parler de ça mais
ce qui est vrai c'est que le thon dont
frais et légèrement menaçant et c'est
pour ça qu'il est menaçant et notamment
il revient sur la sphère benalla sur les
zones d'ombré de la sphère benalla et en
disant la galère financière est
absolument le patrimoine financier du
président de la république donc il ya
toutes sortes de choses qui sont quand
même d'un j'accuse wekiss on avait tous
les ans je ne vois pas un j'accuse sans
mots t'es fait savoir qu'est ce que vous
en pensez
moi je vous le dit fièrement comme
directeur de journal je n'aurais pas
publier la lettre dont frais parce que
alors si vous êtes une question de style
je ne savais pas sa place dans le figaro
magazine
est ce que je leur ai même il aurait
invité s'il avait été responsable d'une
démission a été mise au public bah je
sais pas je vous demande votre avis du
coup moi je ne suis pas tellement
un fan de l'écriture et du ton qui a été
employé sur sur cette lettre qu on est
on est d'accord c'est un style qui est
très particulier qui effectivement
peut-être menaçant mais qui met pas très
à l'aise moi je trouve à la lecture que
c'est plutôt un voilà c'est un peu un
pamphlet mais vraiment alors grossier
graveleux je pense que gérard a raison
dans les mots qu'il emploie est ce que
pour autant ça avoue ça vaut 100 sûr je
ne sais pas d'abord parce que s'est
donnée un peu beaucoup d'importance à
celui qui de fait a écrit a écrit ces
mots et ces phrases et d'autre part
c'est vrai que j'ai l'impression que les
deux font la paire
entre la photo initiale et puis le franc
que j'allais dire on est un peu toujours
on est un peu dans le même mode
ouais c'est quelque chose qui m'a fait
quelque chose qui est très étonnant
qu'il n'y a un peu mal à l'aise et si le
niveau du débat la photo était situé
face à ce point là alors ça interroge un
petit peu beaucoup dans le moment qu'on
sera directement mal à l'aise vous avez
complètement
on est mal à l'aise quand on voit cette
photo parce qu'en se dit qu'enfin on
croit rêver
on est mal à l'aise quand toilettes
boudaya en fait c'est qu'il ya à
l'époque de l'obscénité baudrillard
parler de l'obscénité c est ce qui est
en dehors de la scène le président est
en dehors de la scène présidentielle et
onfray et en dehors de la scène
philosophie si je réponds cherche encore
quelques réactions d'internautes
babineau qui nous dit c'est un essai
satirique délibérément provocateur
accusés on ferait d'homophobie c'est la
meilleure façon de le faire taire anti
mac nous dit l'essentiel c'est la
liberté de parole on ne va quand même
pas traîner tout le monde en justice et
puis il ya cette réflexion que je livre
à votre commentaire zemmour onfray
taddei on vire les opposants pour ce
qu'il ya une volonté de virer ceux qui
pensent pas bien richard bouygues eric
zemmour c'est parce que il a été
déprogrammé à on n'est pas couché
l'émission de laurent ruquier
je ne sais pas ils pensent tous quand
même un petit peu de la même manière ce
conte
ce que vous citez n'ont ils sont enfin
je sais pas j'ai pas cette impression
qui est une volonté de il ya une
tendance un petit peu qui est paradoxal
c'est à la fois on a des gens qui dans
le débat public sont de plus en plus
dans l'affirmation dans la revendication
et qui met sur la table des idées qu'il
ya quelques années on n'aurait pas
entendu il ya un espèce de mouvement
aussi de ballades un peu prêt-à-penser
de surtout ne pas sortir d'un
politiquement correct les deux
s'affrontent un peu moi j'ai vraiment
encore l'impression qu'on est dans
quelque chose d'assez stérile et que sur
ce débat on mériterait un petit peu
autre chose
ja une chose que je veux dire c'est ce
dont on parle là si on avait des
systèmes mon programme pas tous les ans
tous les dix ans tous les 20 ans les
mêmes à la télé peut-être qu'on se
poserait pas cette question c'était
combien de temps que vous m'aurez sur
les ondes
on peut peut-être changé il ya peut-être
d'autres gens à écouter d'autres
intellectuels est vrai d'autres
philosophes des vrais à entendre que ce
lapin qui finalistes c'est pas de sel
oui c'est ça je sais que vos questions
en suspens ce qui fait la vie ce qui
fait délivrer de sûrement dit marchio de
la cédraie présent la république voulait
justement instaurer un espèce de groupe
de réflexion et une législation là
dessus ce marathon à dernier dernier mot
mais juste tient sur moi du journalisme
de service public qui est à réinventer
c'est évident qui fait la liste c'est
une excellente question
et voilà eh bien on restera sur cette
excellente question posée par périco
légasse qui fait la liste point de vue
ça revient demain avec maria mais les
lombards qui fait la liste des invités
c'est nous et on assume assez bien merci
beaucoup de votre fidélité à demain
bonsoir
[Musique]